it was announced today that they
discovered an entirely new pyramid in
Egypt outside of Cairo not far from the
bent pyramid in dr. Egypt now the
information about this site is very
limited every source that I could find
only provided for photos of the entire
site and the all claim that is
approximately thirty seven hundred years
old but yet they have zero sources or
any type of evidence to back that up
whatsoever the information is pretty
much limited to that and as you can see
on these articles that I screenshot here
that's literally all the information
that they provided they know that they
found an inner corridor they know that
they found a stone plaque of some kind
with ten hieroglyphs on it but they have
zero evidence whatsoever of how old it
is who made it in when and in this video
I'm going to show you definitive
evidence in the case of the Great Sphinx
as an example that proves that the true
age of these megalithic sites are far
older than we were ever taught in school
and then what the textbooks currently
state now you've seen all four of these
photographs literally that's all that we
have of it and I scoured the internet
for as much information as I could but
let me take this opportunity to share
with you actual photographs of the
enclosure of the Great Sphinx which
according to Egyptologists and the
minister of Antiquities of Egypt which
provided us the same information on this
newly found pyramid also claims that the
Great Sphinx is approximately 4,500
years old yet despite more than 200
professional geologists from around the
world that have visited the site clearly
state that there is absolute definitive
evidence of water erosion around the
enclosure of the Sphinx now when the
sinks is found it had been buried for
some say thousands of years and there is
evidence of wind erosion on the
limestone of the Great Sphinx that you
can see here however around the
enclosure the evidence of the limestone
water erosion is overwhelming and in
fact you can even look for evidence on
your own on google images of examples of
limestone with wind erosion versus water
erosion and you can see with your own
eyes that yeah literally it is
absolutely water erosion yet here's the
kicker the last times the Nile Delta
received rainfall that could have made
this type of
Oshin was more than 7,000 years ago
that's closer to double the age of what
they're telling us about the Great
Sphinx so it doesn't compute and quite
literally the evidence is overwhelming
that the age of the Great Sphinx and
other megalithic sites from around the
world are far older than what we're
being taught yet despite the
overwhelming evidence mainstream science
archeology just completely disregards
and ignores the subject altogether does
it no wonder why that is
does anyone wonder how they come up with
the figure of a buried newly found
pyramid to just be thirty-seven hundred
years old there's no date on the site
guys so how do they come up with that
and if you study the subject on your own
and utilize this sermon you will see
that well everything's just based on
theories and the overwhelming evidence
concludes that these theories have been
debunked I'll be sure to make another
video as more information comes to light
on this newly discovered pyramid and I
have many videos on this subject as well
anyways guys I'll leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe help me spread the message
and as many other videos and a whole
wide variety of topics take care
everybody